[Music]
all right marisol yeah marisol where are
you from where'd you grow up version um
i was born in waukegan illinois but i
was raised in north chicago so northern
suburbs of chicago yes
and so tell me how you grew up you had
both your parents when you were a kid uh
yeah um
but my mom and dad didn't have the best
relationship
so
they separated when i was eight
and um i am one of seven
siblings i'm number six
and
they my siblings were pretty pretty sad
about the fact that my mom wasn't around
but i was actually
uh
i was actually glad she wasn't around
because she was like
physically abusive to me
um i don't think i have one memory of
having like a regular
childhood where there wasn't any kind of
violence
she
like for example i remember being four
years old and
i had an accident i peed on myself in my
sleep and she came into the room and
she's like what's that smell
and i remember her picking me up
and
taking me to the bathroom taking all of
my clothes off
and turning the cold water and putting
me in the tub
and while the cold water was hitting my
body
she was
spanking me
and
she was saying
she was speaking at the moment but i i
couldn't hear her over the cold
just rushing through my body and and the
pain that my body was feeling from her
hitting me
or another moment where my grandmother
used to watch us when were kids when my
parents used to
go to work
and
i remember being like five or six
and
i was
playing with the neighborhood uh
children
and my grandmother must have said
something to my mom maybe i did
something wrong that day who knows i
don't remember
but she came out of nowhere with a
tree branch
and i just instantly felt like a burn
on the side of my body and i looked up
and it was her and she was like
yelling what did i tell you
and i had no clue what she was talking
about and she just continued to beat me
from one side of the street to the other
and all of the kids were watching and i
just felt so embarrassed
so the abuse was
for you or for all your siblings
uh
it was mostly just me and my older
sister i never seen her uh
use any kind of like violence towards my
brothers at all
it was just me and my older sister
yeah she would beat us with like a wire
hanger
um an extension cord
you name it whatever she could reach for
um
so when she left i i was relieved you
know i was like
maybe i'll get some sort of
some sort of peace
you know maybe
maybe today i don't have to worry about
because she would even beat me if i lost
my socks
and you know i would be
terrified
every day like making sure that i keep
my socks together and
when she left i was like eight years old
and i thought that that was gonna be
the worst of it
but
i was wrong
uh so when um
when she left
uh
my my dad took care of all seven of
us and uh he had to obviously
work full time every day to take care of
seven
children
and he would come home exhausted and he
would still cook for us and
and and clean the house you know and i
know he must have been beyond distracted
my my dad is like
i have so much respect for that man he's
amazing
um
but sadly because
he wasn't
present
even if he was there physically i don't
think he was there mentally because my
mom was the love of his life
and
he was
he was depressed for a while there
so i think he was just in his own little
world for for a little while
um
but anyhow
but then uh
a few months after my mom left
i started getting
sexually abused by
my two oldest siblings
and my two oldest brothers and my older
sister
and um
i'm eight years old so i don't i don't
know what's going on you know i didn't
and then my parents never
talked to me about like if anyone
touches you here is not a good thing or
protect yourself in this way
um
[Music]
they
so anyhow uh
my
so i started getting abused by my older
sister first
and
and it became like
it felt very uncomfortable for me at
first
and
and then it was just happening so often
that i just i it was like an out of body
experience like i would drift away
whenever it was happening and then when
i would stop i would come back and and
it would be as nothing has ever happened
and then um and then
my two oldest brothers started doing it
and
that was really
intense for me
i had no privacy because it would happen
everywhere
i could be taking a shower and
you know i i have a memory of being like
nine and being in the shower
and being picked up and put on on the
sink
and
then proceeding to do things to me
and uh
but
it's crazy your mind has a weird way of
protecting you from your trauma
um
i would do things without even thinking
that i was protecting myself like
when it started happening
i slowly like
would shower less
i would dress in really baggy clothes
because i didn't want i guess in my mind
if i didn't look attractive um
i would be left alone
um
i remember uh
being
i remember always telling i have a
younger sister
and i would wake her up we would share a
room and i would wake her up in the
middle of the night
so she can
go with me to the bathroom and i always
thought like you know maybe i'm just i
don't know afraid of the dark you know
and there would be days where she would
be too upset because who wants to get up
in the middle of the night you know
and um
i would be like can can you go with me
and she would be
too upset
so i would i would say okay
and i would watch her go back to sleep
and i would be sitting there um
in the middle of my room
looking around
and hearing just
pure silence
and
and then next you know i would just be
peeing myself
because i was too afraid
to go to the bathroom
um
my siblings room was next to the
bathroom
and i knew that if i would go
i could disappear for a little while
and um
ah thank you
um
and
so i went on
until i was 16 so it happened for eight
years
literally every single day
i didn't have
i didn't have not one day
to breathe i guess
and um
and they're
and again like
you do things without knowing you're
doing them you know like i i struggled
with um
the smallest things like i i'm super
afraid of the dark you know
i need to have some sort of light
somewhere
uh
or for me being an accomplishment is
being able to sleep alone
you know i
i couldn't sleep alone for for a very
very long time
or even sleep on the outside of the bed
you know because uh
i uh
i would we had bunk beds
my little sister and i and she would
sleep on the top bunk and i would beg
her all the time please sleep with me
and i would sleep
in between the wall and her
because if she was behind me
they wouldn't
mess with me
but the if i was on the outside of the
bed
um
there would be days where i would wake
up and i'm on someone's shoulder
and i'll just look back at my sister and
she's sleeping and then i'll just
but but it's weird how
how i could go into my siblings room
and
and
they would do
horrific things
and i would come out of the room as if
nothing ever happened
like
your mind is
it's a
crazy thing the way it protects you
uh
um
and then uh
because i was going through so much at
home
i began
to become a really angry person you know
hurt people hurt people that's i i feel
like that is so true
uh
i went to uh you know in school and plus
we weren't living in the best of areas
you know we didn't we didn't have much
we struggled a lot like
we were living off one income which is
my dad's bless his heart
and there would be moments where we
didn't have electricity for a little
while or during the summer we didn't
have gas and we would have to boil water
to take a shower
or
seeing rats or
roaches as a normal thing you know like
people would be like oh there's they
will freak out off of a rat or a roach
and i'll just like oh it's whatever to
me you know i was so used to it
and um
and we didn't like i said we grew up
with
close to nothing you know we lived in
like two bedroom apartments and it's
eight of us
or um have to share like really tiny
rooms
um and we were always moving around we
never had a steady place
and uh
so we're dealing with all of that at
home whenever i would go to school i was
just really an angry kid and i was that
kid that was always in like the dean's
office for fighting
every week i was
i was violent
i was just angry you can look at me in
any
weird way and i was already down your
throat you know
and um
or you could say any disrespectful thing
to me and i was already
again like just
i i chose violence every morning
and i think that that was my way of
because whenever i was in these fights i
was never mad at the person who i was
fighting i was always thinking about the
things that were happening to me at home
and i would just take my anger out on
them
um
and then one day
uh i started skipping school
a lot
i think it was my sophomore year
and a teacher asked me
what was going on she was just checking
in
and i was so fed up and so frustrated
that i just wanted to be left alone but
she kept
bothering me
and
i didn't mean to say it out loud because
i swore to myself
i'm going to take this secret to the
grief like no one is going to know
what's happening to me at home
because i felt so embarrassed
so much shame
and disgusted
but i i blurted out
she's like what's wrong what's wrong
because you're crying because of the way
that you're crying you have to be crying
about something else and
and i said
i'm being sexually abused at home
and she stopped
and then i went
and then i said
i'm lying i'm lying i'm kidding i
nothing's happening
it was too late by then
um
she
she ended up reporting it to the
principal and the principal called the
cops
and
and then
a detective
was in my class
and they took me
they took me to the police station and
then they started interrogating me
and and i remember the guy saying
something is happening look at you
and i was like what does he mean by that
but i remember
i was dirty
my hair was full of grease
my clothes probably smelled because
when i was afraid to go to the bathroom
and i would pee on myself i would change
and um i wouldn't shower in the morning
because i would be too afraid to
and i would go to school like that
and um
he started asking me questions like what
is going on and
and and i said i just but i don't want
them to get arrested you know because
they were my siblings
and i
obviously
they were all i knew
and we didn't have my mom and we were
all
pretty close and
i didn't know the difference back then
back then i was just
they're my brothers and i love them and
i want to protect them and i don't want
to i don't want to get them in trouble
and and it's not like
they were bad
bad people to where people can be like
yeah they definitely
committed that crime you know
they were
to everyone else they were really good
people
you know they
they helped people whenever they needed
help they helped my dad whenever he
needed help like
they in the daytime they saved me from
any other person that would try to
disrespect me
or they would protect me from
harm in the daytime
but i would always ask myself well at
night who's going to protect me from
them
and uh so
so they were removed
from
our place
from home
um my older sister was already out of
the picture she got pregnant when she
was 16 so she moved out
um but they removed my
my
my uh brothers
and uh
you say removed
the cops took uh
they
they got arrested for a while
and
i kind of don't want to like say where
they are just that
that's fine yeah
um
so uh
but my dad didn't take it
very well
and my
my two other brothers didn't take it
very well either
they were mad at me
my dad when they were going through the
investigation process you know my dad
was
trying to convince me
to lie
because i mean i i
i guess if i put myself in his shoes
were both his children right
and
i can't i mean i don't have children but
i can't imagine
how it must
feel to to see both of your children
hurting
but it felt like
he was supporting them and i wasn't
getting any support at all
so because i i didn't lie
i told him the truth
my dad was in
my dad and my other siblings stopped
talking to me for a while
it went on like that for maybe about
almost three months where
i was pretty much shunned
and i'm 16 years old and
and i just
blurt out the biggest secret of my life
and
now i don't have
anyone
and um
and i remember being alone
sitting
in my bunk bed
at 16.
and just thinking to myself
what did you do
you just ruined your family
now we're not together
no one's talking to you
you're an idiot
and um
i began to shame myself
i began to blame myself
and
i saw
a bottle of
i think they were advils
on the dresser
and
i couldn't swallow pills
because um
because of my mom like when i was uh
when i was like five
i ended up getting like a fever or
headache or something and she was giving
me
a pill so i can feel better but i
couldn't swallow it
and i would say mom i can't swallow this
you know and and she's like well i'm
going to continue to give you pills
until you swallow one
so there i was in the kitchen just
taking pills until but i couldn't my
like i couldn't even swallow one so i
kept
i kept throwing them out
so
when i looked at the bottle
i grabbed maybe
they took out 12 pills out and i crushed
them
and
i just took a bottle of water
and
down they went
and i just remember laying on the bed
thinking okay
everybody will be better now off now
i won't be here anymore
and i won't have to deal with
any trauma anymore
i just want to be at peace
and i fell asleep
and a few hours later i woke up
and
nothing
you know i was like what the [ __ ]
you chose the wrong drug yeah
i was like what happened
why am i still here
um
but then i i uh
i looked at myself in the mirror and i
said i
i'll never do that again
i said that was
that was silly
and
um
and then we are and then we moved
and my siblings were gone
and i still
i was still the like the black sheep of
the family
uh and because they're my siblings
i have to hear about them all the time
you know in the beginning
when christmas would come around
thanksgiving
any holiday
they would be
skyping them facetiming them
and in the beginning they would force me
to say hi
and and i would do it you know i'd say
hello i'll pretend like nothing ever
happened and then when i leave i feel
i just felt so shitty because
i felt like everyone else didn't
understand
the trauma
they caused
you know i was i was super
depressed i
i still deal with ptsd
and massive anxiety because of it
no no apologies from anyone not at all
to this day not at all
not at all
and um
and then uh
and then i began to um
skip school more
i was super lost
super super lost
i uh and even because of because of the
trauma
i really didn't know what boundaries
were
you know i
i put myself in a lot of situations
that now looking back i shouldn't have
but because no one taught me boundaries
and i was being violated at home
a lot of things that
a normal person would say hey that's a
red flag i'm like i don't i don't i
don't see anything you know like
like for example um
i would hang out with uh
this married couple across the street
and i was maybe
i met them when i was 13
until
until i was 16.
and they were in their late 20s i
believe
and they introduced me to weed
and i would smoke weed with them every
single day
and i remember looking down at the
husband's leg and
he had some
little
like black thing around his ankle and
i'm like what is that i've never seen
that before what is that
and he and his wife said oh he's on
house rest
and i'm like
okay uh what is he on house arrest for
and later on i learned when i got a
little older that he was on house arrest
for
um
raping
an underage girl
and they would do sexual things in front
of me
and i didn't notice that they were um
grooming me
uh he never touched me
um but she would always say sexual
things
around around me and then
they would have sex in front of me
and then
when i turned 18
they asked if i wanted to join them
and
i i said no i'm like i was like no i'm
i'm okay
you know you guys have fun no judgment
you know but but i didn't realize that
i put myself in these
crazy situations because i did i wasn't
taught
boundaries
or
i got a job when i was 14 years old
and i was getting paid like maybe like
five dollars an hour
and my boss was in his mid-40s
and uh
clearly i got the job because you know
my dad couldn't afford much and i just
really just needed shoes or needed
clothes you know it's not even that i
wanted things i
i needed them badly you know
and
this man would always look at me when
and i would work on the weekends and he
would always look at me and say
you're wearing the wrong panties today
and i would just laugh it off again
clueless you know
and
and then he comes up to me and goes
do you want to see a picture of my
girlfriend
i said sure
and it's a 14 year old girl
and then um
sorry
and then he continues to make
like inappropriate comments all the time
every day when i'm working
and he i was work he owned a woman's
clothing store
and
one day he comes up to me he goes how do
you like you know our clothing and i
said it's very nice i like it you know
it i love it i i
i like the looks
and he goes
well why don't you try a few outfits on
for me
and you can keep everything you try on
and
i me coming from a place where i don't
have anything
i said okay
i'll do it
and uh
and then he calls the sick the mall
security guy over
and he's like in his late 40s
and i'm in the fitting room and i'm
trying these
i'm trying the clothes on and i open the
fitting room door
and they're both standing there
and they're asking me to turn around
and
they're saying all these
provocative things to me
and
they start like touching themselves
and i'm just standing there like this is
absolutely like
it's it's so unfortunate
but this was such a normal thing for me
and this was such a
like it's not a big deal you know like
it's not like he's asking me to do
something
worse
because it can be worse
and then i uh
and then i ended up quitting that job
and i never told
i never told my dad i never thought to
to tell someone
about this man
and
and then i met a guy
when i was
16. and he
we started dating each other
and then we started having
we started having sex
but i didn't want to
and i didn't know that i can say no
so i would do it every time it was asked
um
and uh
so life kept just going on
and that relationship became really
abusive like
uh verbally abusive
and i was still
doing things to please him
just because i i thought that that's
what you were meant like that's what
you're supposed to do
and then it became
too verbally abusive
that it we dated for five years it took
me like a good year and a half to
get out of that
relationship
uh
and um
then i
my depression
and
my ptsd
started to get really bad
like i would have um
i'll have nightmares every day
um
i would wake up like
punching
things
um
and now this is like is in my early
twenties i
would go out and get
drunk
like just
just
shit-faced
and i would black out and i wouldn't
remember
remember anything
and uh
and i could be
i would have moments where i would be
super drunk
and
and i would lock myself in the bathroom
because i felt
i guess
i felt like something was coming
for me i guess
but it was my ptsd i i felt like this
huge
amount of fear
and i would just be sitting in the
bathroom just
rocking back and forth crying
um
and i i
i was pretty bad for a while
um
and then one day uh i remember waking up
and just just feeling like okay what are
you doing with yourself
what are what are you doing with your
life
and
and i because of
my trauma
when i was skipping school a lot i
dropped out of high school
because i was i was so lost i
i wasn't worried about
you know
science
you know i careless about that you know
i was trying to survive
but you need an education to
be a successful adult
at least that's what we're all told
uh
and
so my education
just
i was
the system failed me in that department
as well you know
uh
when my
when my parents separated
my mom took me with her for a little
while
for maybe like a year and she never took
me to school
like
because she took me and my younger
sister so
she used me as her babysitter
and
so because i didn't go to school
i was never taught how to read
and
when i went back to with my dad
uh
i was just getting passed on you know
from grade to grade to grade and
here i am
wanting to learn you know i
i love learning
and no
no adult at all seeing that like you
know hey this girl doesn't
know how to read or write maybe we
should teach her that because that's my
job you know
and
no
i remember you know
being like 11
and
or or from seven to like 11
and every birthday you know i people the
adults would tell me if you make a wish
it'll come true
and there i am in front of the cake
every year closing my eyes and just
saying
all i want is to to know how to read
because they wanted to progress
um
and so
luckily when in
in eighth grade uh
a teacher finally noticed that i had
that problem
thank god for him
and he saw that other kids in other
classes were having that problem and he
took all the other kids out put us in
one class and
and
he taught he he taught us the basics
and uh
and i still struggle with it not as much
as i used to thank god
but it definitely
it made me feel like
i couldn't amount to anything
and
and i just it has always made me
feel
like i'm stuck
and i and i so desperately
want to learn i so desperately want to
be
better my biggest fear is being stagnant
so when i woke up that day
and i asked myself what are you doing
like snap out of it you know
i i
it was like i was arguing with myself
i'm like
so you've been through hell and back so
[ __ ] what
you're so so your parents failed you so
what
so the school system failed you so
what
you're 21 years old now do something
about it
or do you want
to be
you want like 20 years 30 years from now
to still be waking up feeling the same
[ __ ] way
and uh
i reached out to a
a therapist
and i got
i got therapy and and
i remember the first day
she said
what do you want to accomplish with this
therapy
and i said i really don't have the
answer right now
all i know is that
there's a wall
in front of me
that's blocking me from living my life
and
i'm ready to kick this [ __ ] down
and
i began the therapy
and therapy is life i cannot say that
enough
it saved my life
that woman is
amazing
and i learned boundaries
finally
and i learned how to fight for myself
and
and uh
most importantly
i learned that
i was not the problem
it wasn't my fault
i shouldn't carry any shame
and
then uh fast forward some years later i
think i was 27
and now i know how crazy this is going
to sound
whether it was a dream or actually
happen i don't care i'll take it
i was sleeping
and
i felt like i woke up
but i couldn't open my
eyes and i don't know if you've ever had
that feeling when you're sitting in the
back seat of a car
and you're
sitting next to the window and you close
your eyes and you just feel the warmth
of the sun
and you can see
you're
like your red eyelids you know
well i i was sleeping
and that's exactly what i was feeling
and i just felt this warmth cover my
body
and this silence
and then
this pure
feeling of
peace
just no worry
no anxiety no
no hate no violence
just pure peace
and then i remember hearing
my voice but it didn't feel like it was
me i know it sounds crazy
but
it said to me
marty you've had enough
maddie it's okay to let go now
it's okay to move on
it's time to forgive
and i opened my eyes and i just started
crying
they cried for like an hour
but i cried with so much joy
and i uh
at the end of that week i
i wrote two letters
for my siblings
and i forgave them
i expressed all the pain that they
caused
i expect expressed that i
had no
depression and ptsd and anxiety
they're like my friends at this point
but i also express that
you don't define me
and i forgive
you and i no longer carry that hurt
or that pain
and that from that moment forward i will
start living for myself
you know
i heard
maya angelou once said
love liberates
and
i want to love myself each and every
single day
so i can liberate myself from all this
trauma
so i can have the ability
to break
these generational chains
of don't ask don't tell
and walk through life with a purpose
because the only person that is stopping
me from doing that is
me so you better watch out
all right marisol thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you
it's powerful thank you
uh
[Music]
[Music]
i mean it's like oh my god
i think it might be